we have new information about the
government 660 billion dollar loan
program known as PPP designed to help
companies retain or rehire workers
during the pandemic The Washington Post
reports nearly 90,000 companies that
received assistance did not say on their
applications if they would use the money
to create jobs many small businesses are
using the loans to save jobs in
communities all across the country
though last week we showed you how store
owners in one Pennsylvania town are
working hard to keep their doors open
and this week Adriana Diaz takes us to
suburban Evanston Illinois just north of
Chicago she found three different
businesses on Main Street they're
working to establish their new normal in
Evanston Illinois a familiar sound is
returning to Main Street traffic was two
months ago there was no traffic on the
street zero terry streaker should know
he's owned guitar works for 40 years
[Music]
they're sound inside the store to jazz
but during the shutdown the music almost
stopped I ran out of money to pay my
people four or five days before the PCP
money came in and he was on Friday and
the following Tuesday was when the pay
TV money hit my account how did you feel
in that moment friends and customers
including out-of-work musicians also
raised more than twenty two thousand
dollars which striker used to cover
payroll for five weeks and while
customers can't come in and browse
they're still plenty of work coming in
everybody is digging out their old
guitar and bringing it in to get it
repaired my shop is overflowing my shop
guys are busy little beavers a few doors
down it's a little quiet inside d-21 fit
studio just a trainer his tripod a
misprint and go dietrich Horton says
he's lucky
just before kovat hit he had just
started expanding into virtual trainings
which became his lifeline during the
pandemics and 85% of the gyms members
have stuck with him a lot of my clients
just say you know well the kind of
comfort with being at home anyway it's
my own gym small space what is it like
for you though when you're used to
having people in your gym and you can
adjust them and watch them through a
tiny little screen oh yeah that tiny
screen kills me now jogging down for one
minute the tiny technology has had a
huge impact he's kept all of his
trainers employed he credits the smaller
overhead that comes with a one-room
operation in the world and to shut down
forcing him like many Main Street
business owners to evolve do you think
you're ever gonna go back to the way it
used to be I think eventually we could
go out to where it used to be where I
want to I'm not sure it's still a far
cry from business as usual all along
Main Street this family-run frame store
will close after a hundred and seventeen
years a business passed down through
four generations of the same family and
the corner Mexican
strong la principal is just getting by
says owner Eric Young what's been the
hardest thing of surviving during this
pandemic I don't know where to start he
had to layoff 15 employees to survive
that's more than half his staff there
are people there are none employment
that are constantly checking you know
when can I come back have you heard of
any job leads that's difficult to hear
but just like at Guitar works
Main Street customers are taking care of
their own leaving generous tips and
sending cash gifts with the largest gift
twenty five hundred twenty five hundred
dollars
we're very very active in the
communities I really feel like the
community recognized that then and they
said hey you guys we want you to survive
indoor dining has resumed in Illinois
but youngest staying outside for now
even opening this side street turned
patio with other Main Street shops what
does it mean in this town to have a
business on Main Street it's kind of an
honor there's this small-town feel yeah
it's to be so engrained in this
community a small town now filled with
the sound of laughter with perhaps a
hint CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz Evanston Illinois
Christians pockets of sunshine all
across the country a great story Adriana